[Music]
who are some investors
you respect the hell out of but would
never try to emulate are there any
people who come to mind
i mean definitely buffett and monger for
one just this them and in general
here's here's kind of the twist on this
i'm not sure there's any investor who i
admire that i would try to emulate and i
think the reason that is is because i
admire them because they have a really
unique skill and by definition most
people including myself don't have that
skill another thing is that a lot of
people who are really successful at
investing were successful in one era but
maybe not necessarily this era so you
can really admire what they did and how
they thought and the risks that they
took in that time but it would never
work today benjamin graham the great
investor who wrote the book the
intelligent investor he's like the
godfather of investing if you tried to
put benjamin graham's techniques to work
today you would fail so incredibly
hard so miserably if you were putting
together like the actual formulas that
he laid out in his book you would fail
miserably so there's really not anyone
that i would really try to emulate i'm a
fairly passive investor and john bogle
who started vanguard i think is probably
the most admirable because it was so
selfless what he did vanguard a lot of
people don't even know this vanguard is
owned by the people who own vanguard
mutual there's no vanguard shareholders
there's no profits there's no dividends
that are played to the owners vanguard
has was made for the benefit of the
people who own the etfs the people who
own the mutual funds and john bogle did
not make that much money for himself
because of that and you could almost
think that like vanguard's low fees like
the amount that you saved in fees is
money that could have gone to john bogle
and john pogel's estate that didn't it's
like he's like this undercover
philanthropist of of finance that i
really admire just because there's so
few other people like that and i think
someone like uh james simons who we
mentioned earlier i think in every field
there's only one person
whose
claim to fame whose competitive
advantage is i'm smarter than everyone
else in tech for 20 or 30 years that
person was bill gates and i think in
finance for the last 20 or 30 years that
person has been james simons who is he
like the only person in the field who
can say
well if you if you ask them the question
what is your competitive advantage they
can say i'm just smarter than everyone
else only one person can say that and
it's james simons uh so it's if you look
at what renaissance technology has has
done and just the results that they've
accumulated and the consistency of what
they've done
it's it's like lebron james times
michael jordan times
tiger woods to the power of michaela
shiffrin it's like it's just like such a
different universe compared to what
anyone else has done that it's just it's
astounding to watch
for a fun and fascinating romp through
different investing styles and very big
personalities
the book more money than god by say
sebastian maliby am i getting that right
something that's right is is very
entertaining
also not a whole lot of styles you would
want to try to emulate unless that is
your sport and you are in there
any other investors besides jim simons
come to mind and the names you've
already mentioned who you think are
truly exceptional now they could i will
expand investor to mean capital
allocator right so it could also be
a ceo of a company
but
i'll let you
pick who you may pick
there's a value investor named monish
probably who is not very well known he's
a fairly small investor he's capped the
size of his fund at a fairly low level
so he's not a household name he's not
like even within investing circles not
many people know who who he is his
returns are incredibly good and he's
just the nicest
wisest fun to be around guy
that that i've that i've met in a long
time like i really look up to him not
just as an investor but just as a as a
person just how he's situated his life
what he aspires to be how he lives his
life is someone who i've really looked
up to for a long time there's
someone who lots of listeners will be
familiar with brent b short who's very
active on twitter as well is an
incredibly successful investor he won't
say that he will deny that but he really
is and he too is just
one of the nicest kindest funniest
people who i've met and most of the time
when he and i talk it's nothing to do
about investing we just talk about life
and our kids and our spouses and whatnot
so i think most of the people who i
really admire as investors it's more
that i admire just how they've lived
their lives and their general life
philosophies and their investing
philosophy stems from that that's true
for for buffett as well
actually there's an interesting thing
about buffett which is that it was so
easy to admire him and still is but when
the book the snowball came out which is
a biography written about buffett by an
author named alice schroeder and it came
out i want to say 2009 something like
that it really makes clear the case that
buffett has not lived a perfect life by
any means and in a lot of instances his
family life has been a disaster i think
that's the right word to use i don't
it's kind of kind of rude to say that
but i think it's really true in some
ways it's good to hear that that like
everyone puts their pants on one leg at
a time in the morning everyone is human
everyone deals with the ups and the
downs of living a life and that he's a
human and also that a lot of the reason
that his family life was troubled at
times is because he was had a singular
devotion in life which was picking the
best stocks and everything else came
second to that everything from his
family on down came second to that in a
way that a lot of people including
myself at one point said i want to be
warren buffett i want to be the next
warren buffett but then you re you read
about what it took to get there and i'm
like no i i want to stay 10 miles away
from that that's a really important
insight to learn is that a lot of these
people who you admire
the reason that you admire them is
because they're so successful and that's
success that they had had enormous costs
associated with it that are easy to
ignore and when i look at that it's like
i can look at pieces of buffett's life
that i admire and pieces of jim simon's
life that i admire but i don't want to
be them because that mega success had so
many costs attached to it that i want to
avoid in my life that's been a really
important observation too for me
you